el señor si se me está perfeccionando su
tiro mortal de tres puntos en la cancha
de baloncesto para uno de sus tiros la
altura del balón en pies la altura del
balón en pies como función de la
distancia horizontal también en pies
como función de la distancia horizontal
en pies de x está trazada abajo así que
como lo que es función de algo es la
altura la altura es función de la
distancia horizontal entonces podemos
suponer que ya es precisamente la altura
de el balón de baloncesto o la altura
por lo tanto el eje y representa la
altura
altura del balón mientras que
pues de que funciona altura pues es
función de la distancia horizontal en
pies por lo tanto x debe ser la
distancia horizontal distancia
horizontal
déjenme lo anoto el eje x va a ser la
distancia horizontal
horizontal que ha recorrido el balón
el señor thyssen está parado en x0 así
que vamos a dibujar al señor 6 en una
versión simplificada de él
hay más o menos está y está arrojando la
pelota de baloncesto el balón de
baloncesto ahí lo está arrojando y
quería que se fuera naranja
allí está arrojando el balón de
baloncesto lo está arrojando a lo que
parece ser una altura de 246 pies y el
balón recorre esta trayectoria el balón
comienza a subir sube sube sube sube
hasta que llega a este punto máximo por
aquí y luego empieza a descender es una
trayectoria parabólica la trayectoria de
su tiro pero aquí cambia abruptamente de
dirección así que sería normal puesto
que el señor si dicen es muy bueno en
basketball suponer que por aquí está la
canasta de basquetbol el tablero esto
que estoy haciendo es mi intento de
dibujar un tablero de básquetbol
pero bueno ahí está la canasta y eso
causa que la pelota de básquetbol el
balón de básquetbol caiga en un ángulo
muchísimo más inclinado pero bueno
entonces parece que alcance este máximo
al parecer está a 10 12 14 16 pies en su
punto máximo el balón y el aro que está
aquí justamente a 26 pies 26 pies del
señor cisen parece que está a una altura
de 10
10 pies sobre el suelo así que si suena
lógico a que éste sea el aro o el
tablero de basquetbol pero bueno el
punto es la trayectoria que sigue el
balón vamos a interpretar cuál es el
significado del máximo en esta función
el máximo como les decía es precisamente
este punto de aquí este punto es el
máximo y que nos dice pues es la altura
máxima porque el eje que representa la
altura la altura máxima a la cual va a
estar el balón en algún punto de su
recorrido está diciendo que
esencialmente el balón alcanza su altura
máxima pues cuando él la distancia
horizontal es de más o menos 14 pies y
la distancia la altura la distancia
vertical es de 16 pies entonces veamos
cuáles son nuestras opciones el borde de
largo de baloncesto está a 10 pies de
altura eso de hecho sí es cierto estamos
suponiendo que este es el borde del aro
de baloncesto y si está a 10 pies de
altura pero no es el significado este
máximo el balón deja las manos del señor
si dicen a una altura de aproximadamente
6 pies
nuevo eso es correcto estábamos diciendo
que el señor si se lanza el balón cuando
el balón está a 6 pies de altura pero
nuevamente ese no es el significado de
este máximo la altura máxima que alcanza
el balón es de 16 pies es justo lo que
está diciendo ahorita que la altura
máxima que puede tomar el balón sube
hasta llegar a los 16 pies y luego
empieza a bajar hacia el aro si alguna
vez han visto las tiras de basquetbol
verán que son como una especie de
parábola así que esto parece ser ser la
opción correcta vamos a ver la última el
señor si se está lanzando su balón desde
unos 26 pies de supongo que del aro y de
hecho esto también es cierto estamos
diciendo que hay hasta 26 pies del señor
si son pero nuevamente esa no es la
interpretación del máximo así que yo
diría que la respuesta correcta es esta